take a fruit roll up guys
[Music]
that's a million dollar business
Courtney Cox continuing to prove she's
the new queen of tick tock I know yeah
the actress channels her inner Chef
Monica Geller to whip up the app's
latest bizarre food Trend make a fruit
roll-up guys
you roll
a little fresh cut him off
[Music]
I enjoy those I like it the Fruit
Roll-Ups and ice cream hack has taken
the Internet by storm
all right question
wow
but it's not the only online craze
Courtney's attempted look at these tenzy
girls so cute
I want to do that watch the star Go full
on gen Z transforming into an influencer
give your business clean
[Music]
he's home
courts even strapped on her dancing
shoes but the routine had an unexpected
ending I can't believe I can't do that
anymore
I can do that
[Music]
that wasn't easy for sure whether it's
on our phones or our TVs Courtney knows
how to make us laugh
and in February she was honored for her
many years of entertaining I think it's
a lot with her very own star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame well happy
Courtney Cox date to you thank you uh
big congratulations I mean you are
cemented in Hollywood history how does
it feel
feels good yeah yeah you should I mean
what a great turnout your friends family
and colleagues Brave the rain to support
UMB here what does that mean to you it
means a lot I actually did know every
single person like there's a lot of them
too yeah it's really sweet yeah and did
you hear those words from Jen and Laura
and I mean and Lisa they were actually
choking up for you too especially when
they unveiled the star for you too what
was it meant to have their support all
these years and also that Sisterhood
I mean they're just incredible friends
and you know I've known them all for so
many years and it just makes me feel so
proud that they showed up and everything
they said I love them I love them so
much
foreign